in Olivia Fernandez is getting used to
life without running water
in her fifth floor Havana apartment
Sheena has to fill up pots buckets and
even her washing machine with drinking
water
people in this building have spent the
last two weeks carrying water up the
stairs because the water pump and the
elevator is broken we've informed the
authorities we keep complaining we don't
know what else to do
Havana's residents are used to ongoing
water problems the situation is now
critical
the city's water system has not been
upgraded since the 1920s and leaking
pipes mean around 50 percent of the
water supply is lost
with crippling U.S sanctions and an
economy that hasn't recovered from the
pandemic the Cuban government doesn't
have enough money to maintain its
infrastructure dozens of people rely on
these water tanks but they're now only
filled up once every few days
many residents are resorting to
Desperate Measures
the manhole when there's water to fill
up we do it in orderly way without
breaking anything
the Cuban government says that more than
a hundred thousand people in the capital
are living without running water
we must do everything we can even the
impossible so that people get water and
monitor who's the most affected so that
water gets to them and we can figure
this out by being outside in the street
for people living in this state shelter
Health can't come soon enough
there's no water in Havana we're going
through a difficult situation we may
have skin diseases soon because we've
gone through so many days without water
yesterday huh
I didn't shower yesterday there's no
water it's hard to sleep
well the Blazing summer continues people
treasure what a little water they have
Ed Augustine Al Jazeera Havana